hasta dónde están dispuestos a llegar en
sus protestas y ya han dicho que se
radicalizarán las movilizaciones
muy buenas noches gracias por este
espacio es importante señalar que las
movilizaciones continuas se han
afianzado las distintas medidas de hecho
en todo el país y se exige la liberación
de leonidas iza mientras tanto las
movilizaciones van a continuar se han
radicalizado y pues prácticamente efecto
el llamamiento por los máximos voceros y
representantes de la conaie al
levantamiento indígena en el país pero a
qué se refieren ustedes cuando hablan de
radicalizar la protesta
bien el momento que mantiene medidas de
esto en 14 provincias
del país es decir más de un 60 por
ciento esto quiere decir acciones como
cierres de vías en el caso de la
amazonía desde donde me encuentro en la
troncal amazónica que cruza es el eje
vial de toda la amazonía entre otras
medidas que se han tomado a nivel
territorial cuando decimos radicalizar
significa que se van a afianzar este
tipo de medidas de hecho incluso en
torno a las ciudades capitales
principales de las distintas ciudades y
no se descarta tampoco una movilización
hacia la capital de quito sí pues no en
las próximas horas prácticamente no se
libera a leonidas iza